>>Erica: So, the moon is
going to be right here.
Remember that we're going to look in
a straight line through the center
of the Earth, so we're going to...
>>Narrator: Erica Waybright
teaches science.
>>Lindsey: -- 90 and 270.
If you have a quarter-moon,
a quarter-moon...
>>Narrator: Lindsey
Pairs teaches math.
>>Lindsey: It shouldn't
look like a crescent at all.
>>Narrator: And they work
in the same classroom.
>>Erica: Pass these
out to each table.
>>Narrator: Like all other
core-subject teachers in the sixth
and seventh grades at YES Prep
North Central, they teach as a team.
>>Katie: Did you have any
connections to this poem,
or did it make you
think of anything else?
>>Narrator: While YES Prep
spends slightly less per student
than other Houston public schools,
the team-teaching approach is an
unusual allocation of resources
that seems to be paying off.
>>Erica: I actually think the
team-teaching model is amazing.
My partner teaches
basically the math portion.
I teach the science portion, but we
do a lot of shared responsibilities.
We do a lot of planning together,
making sure that we're
integrating math and science.
>>Nice job.
>>Narrator: Whether it's math and
science or arts and humanities,
a prime reason for team-teaching is
the integration of subject areas,
which, as studies have shown, results
in deeper understanding for students.
>>Katie: It's hard for teachers at
first to integrate, because they want
to teach their own subject and
teach it well, which obviously needs
to happen, but I think we've learned
that kids love it when we integrate.
They see the connections
a lot more quickly
than I think we ever
thought they would,
and they sort of latch
on to that information.
>>Student: It's waxing, because after
a while it's going to get bigger,
and then it's going to be waning.
>>Erica: Perfect.
>>Katie: Being in a
classroom with 36 kids
by yourself, you'd probably go crazy.
I mean, there's always someone to
help you and to bounce ideas off of,
and it's good for grouping.
We can do a lot more group
work, a lot more centers,
a lot more projects,
where the kids are going
to get the attention they need.
>>What else?
Ms. Knapp?
>>Teacher: I thought of
world's greatest boss,
world's greatest teachers.
>>Katie: Absolutely.
>>Class: [laughs]
>>Philip: We know how important that
collaboration is, not only in terms
of sharing the workload
but, more importantly,
if you have hired two people
that are incredibly intelligent
in a content area, their
lesson's only going to be stronger
by them sharing their
ideas with each other.
I think every single type
of poem we can incorporate
into the different
aspects of community.
>>Narrator: Teacher teams
meet for 50 minutes each day
to strategize and plan lessons.
>>Katie: I think what we talked
about with you having them actually
write poetry in history is huge.
>>Lora: It does take a little
bit of extra time to meet
and make sure our two
subject areas are aligning.
It would be a lot easier to just
do my subject and stay in that box,
but it wouldn't be as beneficial.
>>Why don't I just write the poems
for the lesson on Thursday
and Friday?
>>Narrator: The YES Prep formula for
effective team-teaching includes:
daily 50-minute common planning
sessions for teacher teams,
lesson plans that require active
participation by both teachers,
professional development specific
to best practices in team-teaching.
>>Katie: So, the upcoming week...
>>Hard parts about it?
I mean, personalities have to match.
I've been lucky enough this year
to have a really great team teacher
who we get along perfectly,
but that's always a struggle
for administration, I think, to
put teacher together who're going
to work well together and just
that there's not a lot of research,
I don't feel like, about how
team-teaching can really work,
so we've kind of made
it up as we go along,
and we've learned every year
different ways that we can best use
that relationship, since we're
both there in the classroom.
>>Lora: You guys have the same thing?
>>Narrator: For YES Prep,
team-teaching has provided
smaller teacher-to-student ratios,
deeper student understanding
of subjects and connections
and positive examples of
successful collaboration.
>>Katie: So let's try to
put that into a paraphrase.
>>Lora: I think that team-teaching
models how you can be even more
successful if you can work positively
in a team, so it's really cool
that our students get to see us
every single day interacting,
and they also see us outside
of the classroom interacting
with each other, and they know
that just being in relationships
and having a positive working
environment can help you
be successful.
>>Erica: Make sure you get even
with it and tell me what you see.
Good.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org